now chances are some of you have at
least considered using a high refresh
rate monitor almost every esports title
benefits from screens that go above and
beyond the basic 60 hertz that many
displays have
and until you try one you might not
actually know what you're missing now
i'm one of those people who finds myself
fairly sensitive to high refresh rate i
don't personally like
60 fps panels as soon as i experienced
high refresh rate for the first time i
was hooked like me personally the jump
from 60hz to 144hz was night and day and
you can ask most players going from 144
hertz back to 60hz it really takes away
from the experience it's like seeing
color for the first time it was
absolutely eye-opening and i could never
go back but how much better is a 144 240
or even 360 hertz monitor
can they actually help you rank up in
your favorite games and if so
how do you make sure that you're setting
it up properly
all right i'm sure all of you knew that
this episode was coming but today is the
day that i finally get to talk about
monitors and more specifically high
refresh rate or so called gaming
monitors we've also teamed up with our
pals from amd who have once again helped
us by sharing their expertise now
depending on what games you play your
refresh rates and frames per second
might not actually matter all that much
like if you're just a casual gamer who
enjoys single-player story driven
content then your average 60 hertz
is often just fine and if you are a
console
enthusiast then for a long time 60 fps
was actually all you could muster before
the most recent generation of consoles
the playstation 5 the new xbox series s
and x they were capping out at at best
60 hertz on their displays or maybe even
30. right so going to pc you had the
advantage of getting these high refresh
rate displays you had the really smooth
experience but if you're like me and
countless others in this space then you
definitely take fps pretty seriously now
i'm sure i'll have to tell you but a
vast majority of our audience is
obsessed with games like counter-strike
valorant siege and even league of
legends and all of these games are built
around a competitive game mode where you
can climb your way up the ranks and god
knows the gamers who actually care about
the games they play and desperately want
to improve at them will do just about
anything to gain an advantage and that
includes going out and buying a top of
the line gaming monitor with settings
that most of you probably don't even
understand how to use but let's take a
step back for a second because before
you even go out and buy one of these
high refresh rate monitors you need to
make sure that you own a pc that can
handle churning out such high fps now
for virtually every game ever made
turning your video settings down as low
as possible will help bolster your pc's
performance and if you need help
figuring out which settings you should
turn off or leave on make sure to check
out our pro settings episode from last
year now once you've finished optimizing
your settings then you can finally
starts to decide on a monitor you know
that little fps ticker in the corner of
all your games well turn it on if you
don't see it because this is the easiest
way to help determine what monitor will
best suit your needs now if you are able
to run your game of choice consistently
and i mean consistently at above 150 or
so fps then perhaps a 144 hertz monitor
is best for you but those of you who
have powerful rigs capable of running
games in excess of 300 or maybe even 400
frames per second
might want to opt for an even higher
refresh rate monitor nowadays 240hz and
even 360hz monitors are becoming
increasingly popular but if your
computer can't keep up with your
monitor's refresh rate then please don't
waste your money running your game at a
consistent fps is absolutely critical
don't believe me
well here's my boy robert from amd
to help back me up you'll want to at
least tune the settings such that
your frame rate is pretty consistent at
whatever refresh rate your monitor is so
you're going to need to look into that
you might have a 60 hertz monitor 120
hertz
heck even like 280 or 300 these days and
you want to try to dial in a frame rate
in the game that's very close or beyond
what your monitor can do and that means
you're always seeing
sort of the the latest most updated
information from the game which is
especially important for games like cs
go or other twitchy shooters now if your
frame rate is out of sync with your
monitor's refresh rate then you might
experience something called screen
tearing and if you think i'm about to
explain screen tearing
then you've clearly never watched this
show because that's not gonna happen
this is when colton comes in and
spews nerd stuff at you and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about presented by amd at this point do
i just exist to answer dimitri's tech
questions watched vtubers and field
desperate dms asking for a virtual riot
themed gun attachment
man i need something to distract me from
this existential dread
oh right screen tearing before we talk
specifically about screen tearing i want
to explain how your monitor actually
updates the image on your screen in old
crt displays the visual data was
translated and sent to a literal ray gun
firing an electron beam at a phosphor
layer the gun would move from left to
right top to bottom one row at a time
creating the image on your display
modern monitors actually update in a
similar way the data stream from your pc
is translated and then the pixels will
update in that exact same pattern left
to right top to bottom so why is all
this important to understand what screen
tearing is well if your pc is sending
frames out of sync with your monitor's
refresh rate you could be getting a new
frame's data in the middle of drawing
the previous one creating a weird
horizontal tear in the image
that's the name there are generally two
routes you can go down when trying to
fix issues with screen tearing in one
hand you have tech and in the other hand
brute force when it comes to tech your
baseline option is an in-game setting
called v-sync which just makes your
graphics card wait to send it a new
frame until the previous one has already
been drawn the downside to v-sync is
that it can create a lot of unnecessary
input lag then in the mid-2010s we got a
much more nuanced solution amd's
freesync technology and nvidia's
equivalent g-sync allow your computer
and monitor to update in well sync with
each other which helps eliminate any
sort of screen tearing well this option
will keep your visual fidelity without
costing you the input latency that vsync
has it isn't necessarily as fast as we
can possibly go
for that we have the other hand
brute force many competitive gamers have
turned to just pumping out as many
frames as possible to ensure that any
tearing is on screen for such a short
window of time that it's essentially
imperceptible to the human eye this
gives you the absolute bleeding edge
when it comes to latency at the cost of
needing some combination of exceptional
hardware and lower in-game settings to
reach these frame rates if you're a
relatively casual gamer who just cares
about visual fidelity then 144hz monitor
with something like freesync is probably
going to do you just fine if you're a
competitor who wants to be at the
absolute top of your game
the sky's the limit push your frames as
high as you possibly can and find that
sweet spot between your budget and the
refresh rate you want and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about presented by amd
so we've already told you that monitors
with a higher than 60 hertz refresh rate
are just better
but why is that like if you're playing a
first person shooter for instance
where will you actually notice the
difference well one of the most common
places where one's gameplay might
improve is with respect to reaction time
on higher refresh rate displays you are
seeing the information sooner and this
is pretty obvious since your monitor is
drawing more new images with less space
between each frame so if you're holding
an angle and waiting for your opponent
to peak you then you'll be able to react
faster and take your shot but there does
come a point where you might start to
see diminishing returns the number one
question i get from literally anyone
who's ever used a 144hz display is
whether they should eventually upgrade
to a 240 or now even
360hz monitor and according to youtube
tech god linus it just might not be all
that worth it 60hz displays are showing
you a new frame about every 16 and a
half milliseconds whereas 120 to 144
hertz
that's a new frame about every seven
milliseconds that means that whatever
you're looking at in that comparison is
going to be twice as to date then
when we jump from 144 to 240 that only
shaves three more milliseconds off and
finally going from 240 to 360
that's an extra 120 refreshes per second
above the existing fastest monitors
around
for a whopping savings of just 1.4
milliseconds each frame so the jump from
60 hertz to 144 hertz
is very drastic and once you try it
i think it's fair to say that you will
quite literally never be able to go back
like me personally the jump from 60hz to
144hz was night and day and you can ask
most players going from 144 hertz back
to 60hz it really takes away from the
experience 60 hertz um
it just it's awful man it's awful it's
it's
it it really is a big once once you go
to 144 and above i feel like the
difference from 144 to 240 isn't enough
to like like like it's not like a
must-have
but definitely from 60 to 144 is the
biggest thing you'll ever touch in your
life not even like the refr it's just
like the input lag is just so noticeable
the
just just it just makes the game look
completely different so yeah no if you
don't have a a 144 hertz get one a step
for those of us who have experienced the
beauty of a true high refresh rate
masterpiece
60 hertz just doesn't cut it anymore
like don't get me wrong it can be used
to view your twitch chat or for
completing basic tasks but i don't
advise playing ranked on one unless you
absolutely have to but beyond 144 hertz
the performance boost just isn't as
obvious the jump to 240 or 360 or even
390 hertz it's just a lot less impactful
hell some pros like tens have even
suggested that 360 hertz just feels kind
of weird so if you're like an actual
competitor is it worth it to dish out
the cash for a 360 hertz or even 390
hertz display
well to answer that question we
consulted our go to valerian streamer
ethos the improvement you get
uh
decreases the higher you go up right so
60 to 144 absolutely worth it it's a
must-have 144 to 240 if you got a little
bit more money um definitely investing
it 240s still definitely a great
improvement as a it's a lot less
noticeable than 144 and for a lot of
people they have mid-tier systems and
they can't even maintain above 240. um
going from 240 to 360 and above
i wouldn't i wouldn't recommend i think
if you already have a 240 then just
leave it at that keep your 240 and then
and that's that does a higher refresh
rate monitor technically provide faster
more up-to-date visuals
yes the real question is whether those
improvements are actually perceptible to
you and
if they'll actually help your gameplay
more than say spending some extra time
practicing the average gamer might not
see the point in pumping extra money
into their peripherals but for the best
players in the world 240 hertz and
beyond
is definitely becoming the standard just
like 60 hertz was the norm only a few
years ago 144 and 240 hertz displays are
becoming more and more common and the
best part about all of this is that the
price of these products has dropped
significantly so maybe it's finally time
for you to make the jump to a higher
refresh rate but if you or your wallet
is not quite ready to pull the trigger
on a new display and you still want to
rank up in your games
then
maybe it's just time you hit the
practice server
is it 144 240 or even 360.
you want to say degree
so is it actually worth buying a 360 or
even 390 degree degree
also we got to get the engineers working
on a 390 degree monitor that sounds
pretty dope that does sound really dope
yeah
not going to see [ __ ]
i'm going to be the worst for
performance i'm literally not going to
know where anybody is
it's going to be great literally
spinning in your chair yeah
yeah that's the mistake though and if
they'll actually help your gameplay that
was an incredible voice crack
gameplay